It seems that Emperor Palpatine owes his epic
Star Wars return to another guy's exit — that's
according to a new interview with Colin Trevorrow
in Empire — the magazine, not the pan-galactic
evil organization.
During this interview, Trevorrow, who was
at one point attached to write and direct
the ninth film in the Skywalker Saga, revealed
that it was J.J. Abrams who decided to bring
back the iconic character.
“Haha.”
Trevorrow's remarks to Empire focused on his
time working on Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker,
which he and his writing partner Derek Connolly
departed in September 2017.
The director, who is best known as the driving
creative force behind the Jurassic World franchise,
told the magazine that the return of the notorious
Sith Lord was the story element that finally
helped the rest of the film's plot fall into
place.
He explained:
"Bringing back the Emperor was an idea J.J.
brought to the table when he came on board.
It's honestly something I never considered.
I commend him for it.
This was a tough story to unlock, and he found
the key."
Trevorrow spent enough time working on The
Rise of Skywalker to score a story credit,
but he wasn't willing to go into detail when
asked about his specific contributions to
the script.
He told Empire:
"That's not my place, especially right now.
I know how hard this crew has worked over
the past two years, a lot of them are working
with us now on [the next Jurassic World movie].
I want to support them as they put this film
out into the world.
In the end, I'm just proud to have my name
in space."
He did, however, give credit to Abrams for
keeping what worked and jettisoning what didn't
in regard to The Rise of Skywalker's story.
Trevorrow explained:
"I'm not sure anyone who chooses the creative
life should expect things.
But I'm grateful to JJ for embracing some
of our ideas.
It's exciting that fans will get to see the
moments that felt essential to all of us."
Abrams, of course, co-wrote and directed 2015's
The Force Awakens and in a recent conversation
with Uproxx, the director revealed that the
seeds for Emperor Palpatine's eventual return
had been planted all the way back when that
film was still in the scripting stage.
Abrams said:
"When you look at this as nine chapters of
a story, perhaps the weirder thing would be
if Palpatine didn't return.
[...] Strangely, his absence entirely from
the third trilogy would be conspicuous.
[...] When [co-writer Lawrence] Kasdan and
I worked on The Force Awakens, we didn't do
it in a vacuum.
We very purposely looked at what came before
[...] to ask, where does this feel like it's
going?"
Fortunately, The Last Jedi director Rian Johnson
didn't step on Abrams' toes in crafting that
film's story.
Abrams remembered:
"When Rian was brought on, we met and we talked
about things, and he wrote his story.
And when I read the script, I realized this
didn't get in the way of anything [Kasdan]
and I talked about."
As it turns out, that particular stroke of
luck has been significant to the production
of The Last Jedi's upcoming sequel.
Abrams continued:
"There were some very specific things we did
get to do in [Rise of Skywalker] that we were
laughing and going, 'Oh my god, we're finally
doing that thing we talked about five years
ago.'"
Of course, Palpatine's role in the movie is
still a total mystery, so nobody can be sure
exactly what Abrams and Kasdan talked about
a half decade ago that will finally come to
fruition.
Did the Emperor survive being tossed into
a seemingly bottomless abyss by Anakin Skywalker
at the conclusion of Return of the Jedi?
Or was he resurrected through some arcane
means, possibly by harnessing the mysterious
power of the Dark Side of the Force?
Above all else, what on earth could his master
plan possibly be, and how does it involve
the burgeoning Jedi Rey and Kylo Ren, heir
apparent to the Empire's legacy?
Only time will tell.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.